all right elizabeth
welcome back
so your last talk was it was a really
interesting one
and it'd be nice to talk to you talk to
you about
how you got to where you're where you
are today how your thinking helped you
steer your life
yeah that's definitely my intention um
first of all
thank you so much to
everybody that took the time to watch my
video
because you know we live in a time of
society where people want things in 30
seconds or less and you know that video
was almost 40 minutes long and
the fact that so many people
took time out of their life to watch
that it really means a lot to me it was
very humbling um
and then you know just the comments i i
did my best to read
um
you know all the comments and and thank
you for that and you know that the truth
is
you know me playing big like this
playing full out and not playing small
anymore i kind of realized the reason
that i did play small
for so much of my life was because i
didn't want anyone to criticize me i
didn't want to feel hurt i you know i
couldn't take it it was like i had no
skin
and
you know the comments that were negative
you know towards me or whatever
in a way i almost thank those people
because it gives me an opportunity to
see where i'm really at
because it's easy to be okay with myself
you know when people are kissing mass
like oh you're so great you know it
everybody loves that but it's it's in
those times when when people
you know poke at you or challenge you
you know it's like wait a minute i know
who i am
and anyone that's in my personal life
that knows me
knows they know who i am you know and i
have the saying like what people think
of me means nothing but how people
experience me is everything
and that's really what i stand by you
know so
bring it
[Laughter]
bring it you know say the good the bad
the ugly i don't care i i take all of it
in stride so thank you to everyone you
know that
watched and even you know made negative
comments it's it's all good i find for
myself it helps
to not take either one the positive or
the negative ones too seriously yeah
because that's ego like the positive
comments i just like yeah yeah yeah and
the negative comments i can
you know
i'm human so you end up
feeling the negative you know initially
your first reaction is like oh it's
something negative i gotta listen to it
right but if if you if you discount the
positive ones and just listen to
yourself
you'll do the same thing with the
negative ones absolutely yeah because
that that is the trap of the ego it's
like you know that can become very
addicting having people like you or
compliment you or you know agree with
you or whatever so anyways
um
but the the main reason i wanted to come
back on is
you know i feel like
we all have a story we we all came
you know to this earth with a soul
contract that's what i call it
and
some people do better than others and
for whatever reason i've
i've come out of
some really really hard dark times and
i think the most
important thing is that i feel good
about who i am today
so the energy behind me sharing
the the difficulties and the pain is no
longer about like
me being a victim or a martyr or you
know i used to share stuff with people
and really what i was doing was i was
kind of creating like an insurance
policy for when i didn't show up
so i could be like yeah but i told you i
went through that you know and and it
was very manipulative you know i
manipulated a lot of people in my past
and
the energy today that i share from is
like look i did this and if i can do it
so can you you know i'm showing up in my
life
despite what i went through
and
that is such a huge shift in energy for
me that's just that's such a victory
um
so yeah i feel like i want to just give
more you know give what i can as far as
like information and just you know my
personal experience and and what i
believe and
and how i've i've gotten through this so
i got to a point where you know stuff
got so dark and i felt so lost and
this question
kept coming up and it's who am i
who am i
and i just kept asking that question it
was like i almost became kind of
obsessed with it and
i'm definitely a natural seeker
i like to figure things out
um
[Music]
so
when i finally you know got off of drugs
and i cleared some space in my mind and
in my psyche and everything you know i
i've shared before how i did a lot of
meditation and i did a lot of reading
and a lot of just soul searching and
what i came up with and this is just my
opinion you know take what you want
leave the rest you know
and i always
leave room for what i think is is not
even true you know i i'm i'm not someone
who's like you have to believe this you
know it's that's not that's not where
i'm coming from at all
but
um the way i kind of look at the whole
situation
with my parents
with my family
um
and this life is you know
i believe that my soul and my spirit is
eternal
and
i can't really explain eternal because
it's kind of mind-blowing because if
there's no beginning and there's no end
how do i explain it
so
what i started asking myself was
where was i before i was this
before i was this person doing this
where was i
and
you know kind of what i came up with was
that i had been here before
and
that my soul was it was kind of like
elevating like it wanted to learn more
and more and more and
along the way
i had you know created karma for myself
and for other people
so
if i look at the life that i just you
know or the life that i i'm living but
my past the the difficulties of my past
it's like wow i had some severe karma to
clear
which brought me to
you know who was i before i was this
person what was i doing how was i
treating people well the truth is is
everything that was done to me in this
life
i did to other people
so it's like okay so
that's where the forgiveness piece comes
in
and it's like i
forgive people
because i so badly need to be forgiven
and it's it's it's kind of like
how do i i want to explain this so that
people can can understand that makes
perfect sense though does it okay okay
so the way that i look at it is my mom
and dad
the the vehicles that brought me here
into this physical
existence
on a spiritual level they loved me
enough and loved me enough to have
played this role in my life so that i
could go through these things
and experience
these things
and sort of play with how i was going to
deal with it you know was i going to
become a drug addict and become homeless
and kill myself and that was the you
know what i mean or
i was given an opportunity
to
really overcome some difficult things
so
you know it's like people are like you
know how can you forgive your dad how
can you know what a what an [ __ ] you
know
well
you don't you don't do it for him no you
do it for you exactly and i spent a lot
of years you know because this is what
and this is the other piece to it too is
trauma like what trauma does to us
psychologically
is it sort of gives you like a sort of
like a people
uh perspective of life and and the truth
is is the bigger picture is where the
answer is
you know it's it's like i was so stuck
in like my childhood and what he did and
how i felt and what he didn't do and you
know um
and it just it was like such a small
tiny piece of the puzzle
you know um
and as i've recovered you know from all
of this it's like my
my vision of life and of everything has
just kind of expanded and expanded and
expanded
and i think it's going to expand even
more that's like every day it's like i
just want to be more expansive i want to
understand more i want to love more i
want to experience more
i want to take up more space in the
world
so
you know if my mom and dad loved me
enough to
play this role and and they created
karma for themselves
you know
i think i felt really separate from my
family because i feel like the reason i
was here was very different from the
reason that they were here
you know i don't know
what my mom's doing on the other side i
don't have answers for that but i'm sure
that she's working stuff out that she
couldn't work out here
and same with my brother you know my
brother steve
who passed away
huh who passed away yeah he passed yeah
he passed away and it's really
interesting because i just turned 48 and
he died when he was 48 and i can't
imagine leaving right now
it's like he had i mean
you know we go and we're supposed to go
but he had a lot of life ahead of him
so
you know i think he's working stuff out
on the other side also how did he die
you know i i want to be careful about
what i say because i i i personally
think he got mixed up with some
with some people that might have been
dangerous
um
you know he supposedly just laid down on
the couch
his housekeeper found him you know it
looked like he was taking a nap and the
whole autopsy thing was sort of
inconclusive
and this is what's really weird
i asked my dad this was a couple months
ago and i said dad who identified
steve's body
and he said none of us did
and i was like what like
why
and he said well that you know they said
it wasn't necessary you know i was like
that's
the whole situation honestly was just
very bizarre
and i i don't
want to spend my time here trying to
figure it out i i know he's on the other
side and he's safe
and that's what really matters to me
um
it's really funny because people are
leaving comments like oh yeah life must
be really hard when you're a millionaire
and i'm like where are they getting this
millionaire stuff from and i looked it
up
and it said steve bridges net worth 60
million dollars and i was like what
your your brother was a
he's a comedian that
he wasn't worth 60 million dollars it's
like there's so much stuff out there
that's just not true you know we have to
we all have to be very careful um
what we listen to and believe but
anyways i digress
but yeah steve i love you
wherever you are
i hope you're doing well
um
[Music]
but yeah it's
it's really interesting you know just
sitting here with you i sort of feel
like i'm i'm on purpose right now like
i'm
i'm doing what i'm supposed to be doing
and i had this memory the other day it
was really interesting um
it was when i
the first time i 51 50 myself i think i
was 28 years old and i'd you know broken
up with that guy and
i'm in the psych ward right
and this lady comes up to me she worked
there
she goes you know elizabeth we'd like to
interview you and i was like
what
she goes yeah she goes um there's
there's a group of interns that you know
really need to talk to someone that's
here in the psych ward and i said okay
you know
and i go into this room and there's this
this room full of people and these white
coats and they're asking me questions
you know and
and you know they're asking me like what
what what happened like how did you get
here
you know and i'm just telling them very
matter of fact you know this is what
happened this is why i'm here and
and now that i think back on that
scenario i think that's kind of odd
you know it's like
who who does that happen to like
so i feel like even you know in the
psych ward i still have really important
things to say
it's just really fascinating to me um
you know and i'm i mean i'm joking and
i'm not joking i think one of the
biggest things i needed to overcome was
that i was just super [ __ ] up
you know it's like i think even when i
thought i was really messed up other
people saw something different
why do you think that was
they were they were so [ __ ] up
you know i i think because of the way my
parents my parents treated me i think
that you know
there's what happens you know there's
what someone does
and and there's what what happens and
then there's kind of how it gets
processed by the other person and i and
i think that what i took on the belief
that i took on was that i was unlovable
i wasn't lovable that's common
yeah
and so
what ended up happening was i attracted
a bunch of people that confirmed that
like oh you're not low you think you're
not lovable okay i won't love you you'll
subconsciously attract these kind of
people exactly exactly and
and reject ones that are
that are trying to yeah and i would say
that you know even today i'm
i'm really far from perfect
[Music]
[Laughter]
i you know
i think that there comes a
responsibility with you know
putting myself out there like this
am i out in the world you know harming
people and doing harm and hurting myself
absolutely not
but in no way am i perfect you know i
still get triggered i still get upset i
still have expectations you know um
and it's a daily
effort to to try to be the best person
that i can be
it's it's not um
it's it's like working out you know i
want to keep my body in shape so i got
to go to the gym
yeah
so you know
i was just with my dad
last week and
you know sometimes when i sit with him i
still feel uncomfortable feelings
you know because there's kind of an
unresolved
energy between us you know he
he never admitted
what he did you know the full extent of
what he did and he won't
and the thing is i got to a place where
i didn't need him to and that was such
freedom
you know i think
another one of the big traps that we get
stuck in is like you know i need closure
i need this person to give me closure
and the truth is is like i can only give
myself closure
you know i i can't put that on someone
else
the thing i hear over and over and over
again and all these interviews i do
especially down here in skid row is
i'm a victim i'm a victim i'm a victim
and if you have that victim mentality
you're gonna
you're gonna need that other person to
for you know
apologize and and all that
and if you
don't
see yourself as a victim you're just
going to
brush it off and be like that was
that was messed up that was a bad
period of my life and you just move on
and you don't wear it for the rest of
your life yeah
yeah and there's a there's a woman her
name is carolyn miss
and she did a cd called
why people don't heal and how they can
and she explains it really well that you
know our wounds are sort of like street
currency
and
it's almost like whoever has the biggest
problem in the room
has the most value
so i think at a young age we kind of
learn that you know if you get hurt what
happens someone comes and comforts you
you know it's
and if you're if you're running around
and you're fine nobody really pays
attention to you
so i think we get
you know conditioned at a very young age
to act hurt if we want something or if
we need something
and for people that have been through a
lot of trauma this can become a very
valuable currency
it's it's a way to not really show up
for life
you know it's like
like what i said before you know i would
tell people
you know i'd been molested and abused
and they would kind of you know i
remember one time this girl was like why
are you telling me this she got really
irritated because i think she could
sense you know like this is
inappropriate why are you telling you
know there's why are you telling me this
and i remember being like what am i
telling her that and then it was sort of
like something clicked and i was like
why am i you know i started to really
question myself like why am i telling
this to people like what am i doing and
then
when i listen to
to carol and miss explain it you know it
was it was literally like i was creating
a safety net for when i didn't show up
for when i acted like a jerk
you know or when i lied or you know
whatever when i didn't do what i say i
was gonna do or
um
you know just somehow
didn't have integrity i think that's
what it is
i think it's like well i'm too damaged
to be in integrity
because i told you
you know what happened to me
and a lot of times too
like you know i
right now with what's going on in the
world you know you someone can yell at
you for something and if you tell them
you have a health problem they're like
oh i'm sorry you know what i mean
so this is kind of like it's it's kind
of like a thing in our culture and it's
it's not healthy
it's really not healthy
um
you know so my goal right now is to show
up fully in my life and playful out you
know stop being small and stop being
scared and just
take risks like that's a big thing is
take a lot of risks i mean i you know
emailing you i didn't know what you were
gonna say you might have been like nah
that's all right you know and that's and
that's the other thing is like taking
the risk and if i if i feel rejected or
if i don't get what i want how do i deal
with that
because that's really where the growth
is like that's really where i get to see
who i am because once again if i'm
always getting what i want people are
always doing what i want
it's it's easy to just you know
if you're hungry to learn
which i am yeah
failures almost becomes like more
valuable than
absolutely absolutely because again it's
like how am i going to act when someone
tells me no
can i stay in relation with people when
they don't give me what i want that's a
big one
you know
because if i can do that then i know
that i'm actually
i'm living in a loving place
and again that's not to say that like
stuff doesn't happen and i feel upset
and i allow myself to feel upset
but at some point you know i don't want
to stay i don't want to stay there
that's self-destructive and i can't
really create from that place
it's
it's not fun
not fun at all
um
you know but if there's like
if there's three tidbits
i could i could give everyone
and it's really simple it's like
slow down
just slow down like we are all so in a
rush and in fight or flight
and
if we could just slow down
and then the second thing is just
breathe
like just remember to breathe breathe
deep breathe into your belly into your
chest like really really breathe
and then the third thing is is just have
a sense of humor
like
people that are super super serious and
you know like negative and angry all the
time like those people are gonna live a
very long and unhappy life like life is
gonna be really hard but having a sense
of humor and just bringing levity
to this world is so important
i mean i'm actually after everything
i've been through i'm actually a really
silly person you know i have like 32
different nicknames for my dog and i
love to make chicken noises and you know
it's like
it's just
my sense of humor has really um
has really been a wonderful thing
it's really been
it's been great actually
laughing is magical
pardon laughing is magical laughing is
magical yeah it's medicine it's medicine
absolutely absolutely so
um
i wanted to just touch on something
after i got sober after i got off of
drugs and alcohol um
like a year after i still really felt
crappy
like i was still really struggling with
depression and i was like what's going
on and
um
your drug
yeah crystal meth and i would you know i
would take pills sometimes opiates
how did you stop you you tapered off or
you just stopped i just stopped and how
how long did it take for your brain to
i adjust to be really honest with you i
ca and i can't explain it it didn't take
long
it really didn't i you know there's
certain things that i can't explain kind
of like how i went to the hospital and
took lexapro like three hours later i
felt better i can't explain that
um
i think what happens is like when we as
humans or whatever or me when i choose
to do something to help myself
god kind of meets me there it's sort of
like okay it's like when when your
parents say
you know if if you raise 200 i'll give
you 200 it's sort of like that it's sort
of like when i choose to step up and and
really show up for myself i feel like i
have all this support
so i'm really grateful for that um
but it was it was sort of like i had to
deal with
what i had done to my body physically
and everything that i had been through
had manifested in my body
so i realized that i had something
called candida
which will make a person feel crazy like
it will literally make you feel crazy um
and one of the biggest emotional
side effects of candida is is holding on
to resentments it just it keeps you
angry i was so angry
so um
and candida is basically having too much
sugar in your it's it's actually a
fungus in your gut it's overgrown
yeah yeah it's fed by sugar but it's
also it has an emotional and spiritual
component so
a lot of people that have candida that
they can't get rid of it's because
there's repressed rage and a lot of
codependency happening
so it made perfect sense you know i had
to i had to just repress my rage and i
took on my dad's rage you know
physically and energetically
so i did a um
i did a sugar cleanse and i didn't eat
any sugar at all and for three weeks i
felt completely nuts like it was it was
one of the worst withdrawals i've ever
been through
but after that three weeks i literally
had a spiritual awakening
it was
it was unbelievable like it was
i was like oh my god this is how we're
supposed to feel you know it was like it
was almost like the crystal like how the
crystal meth made me feel this sort of
made me feel that way it was like i had
energy and things looked really clear
and
so
that was really um
that was the beginning of of healing my
body physically
but um you know i also did like tons of
like weekend seminars you know i got a
lot of outside help um i've probably
been a member of
every 12-step program that exists you
know i it
you know i tried it it worked some i
stayed in some i didn't whatever um
and i also
did a lot of hypnotherapy a lot of
meditation stuff um
and just
a lot of just sitting with myself like
sitting with the the pain that i felt
just sitting with it it was like oh my
god i can't bear this any longer and and
if i just sat with it it would usually
like just dissipate but i think as
humans we spend a lot of our time
running from those feelings it's like i
can't i can't take it i can't face it
and the truth is like you can like if i
could
anyone can
um
but another another modality that i use
that i just want to touch on really
quick is
plant medicine
i went to rosarito mexico in 2017
and i did three different kinds of plant
medicine i did something called ibogaine
and i did something called toad it's 5
emo 5 amu or something like that
and then i did ayahuasca
and
the the one that
was the most profound was the toad
and it's literally venom that they get
from these toads that live underground
these shamans and um
i was in this room with this kid and and
he he looked at me he was this young kid
and he goes do you know what you're
about to do and i was like i really have
no idea and he goes well you might face
your own death and i said let's not talk
about it anymore i just want to do it
let's just do it because if i think
about it too much i'm going to freak out
so um and you have to smoke it and you
smoke it out of a glass pipe which was
kind of triggering too i was like i feel
like i'm doing drugs like okay
um
but what i experienced under the
influence of that
it was so beautiful and so profound and
i i saw a like a spinning vortex in
front of me and i i lifted out of my
body i definitely left my body and i
went into the spinning vortex and what i
experienced there
was
pure consciousness
like i became pure consciousness there
was no separation like it was like
everything was everything and
the
the level of love that i felt was almost
more than i could bear like i can't even
explain it
and as soon as i was kind of like able
to
just relax into that
you know because part there was part of
my mind that was like i cannot believe
this is happening i was like i can't
believe this is happening and then once
i stopped asking you know doing that and
just kind of went into it
i was pulled back into my body
and
everything that i ever suppressed came
out
like everything and there were things
that were not from this lifetime like
there were things i was like i don't
remember i don't remember that happening
what is this
like
you know and i screamed and howled like
like an animal for about 30 minutes
like it was
it was it was so intense like it was so
intense i was grabbing the kid next to
me and
saying to him please don't leave me
don't make me feel this by myself
and
as the you know as the medicine wore off
the pain kind of dissipated but what i
walked away from
that situation the message that i got
was that
my tank was so empty like love wise and
just on the receiving end like i had
received so little in my life that i was
like starving but yet i kept giving
so i was giving from such a such a place
of starvation but all i could do was
just keep giving because i
i didn't know how to receive
and that was very profound that feeling
i was like i've got to stop doing that
like that is not okay like i can't keep
doing that to myself
so
and then the byproduct of that was after
that like i could talk about things and
i didn't feel triggered i wasn't like
almost on the brink of tears all the
time
you know so so i like literally
physically and energetically released
so much pain and so much trauma that it
it permanently changed me for the better
you know it was it was really
it was really beautiful and this is from
smoking toad venom yes
in mexico yes
yes i highly recommend it they use it
for like vietnam vets that have you know
that are just more than ayahuasca
you know
by the time i got to the ayahuasca i had
done i think i had released so much that
you know they call her mama ayahuasca
she was just sort of like you know
sweetie just relax like i sort of felt
like i was on mdma like i felt kind of
warm and fuzzy and
i was witnessing people around me you
know like dancing and howling and
barfing and you know doing all these
things and i just wasn't there you know
i just i was kind of like i felt sort of
like the feeling i got from the
ayahuasca was that
i was getting the feel-good hormones
that i didn't get from my mom
it was it was sort of like i felt like i
was being held against like someone's
warm chest
it was it was really nice but yeah i
mean
the toad is the most intense that you
can possibly do
um and it's not as long like the
ayahuasca sometimes you have to like
fast and
you know it's like three nights or two
nights or whatever and this can all be
kind of
over within like 45 minutes
so
yeah um
i'm trying to think what else
you know
yeah i mean
if there's just one message i have for
people it's like just don't give up
just don't give up and and if you need
help oh my god you know it's it's so
amazing to me how scared people are to
get help it's like just get some help
you know there's so much help out there
there's so many people that want to help
and that can help and
there's so many different modalities of
you know therapy and
and
you know ways that we can get support
like just get support you know talk to
somebody don't don't keep stuff inside
don't keep secrets like you know this
this thing that we that we have in this
society of like you know i've got to
keep this persona and look really good
and whatever it's like [ __ ] that
you know if you're hurting let someone
know you know
people do care like at the end of the
day i think that i think that people
really do care
i think we just have to let it happen
you know i know i did
i have more love around me right now
than i've ever had in my entire life
it's really a blessing
yeah
excellent
all right elizabeth thank you so much
for coming in again thanks mark super
interesting take care guys thank you
you